-Amis téléspectateurs,
bonsoir et merci
à celles et ceux
qui nous rejoignent sur LCP.
Ce mois-ci, on s'intéresse
à un sujet qui nous concerne tous :
l'eau, celle que nous buvons,
que nous utilisons,
celle aussi
que nous gaspillons.
L'eau est devenue un enjeu
stratégique et politique
car l'eau ne coule plus
de source.
Elle se fait même
de plus en plus rare.
Canicules, sécheresses,
rivières à sec
et nappes phréatiques
au plus bas :
l'eau est le nouvel or bleu
que tout le monde s'arrache,
parfois violement.
Si l'eau
est un bien commun, tout le monde
n'est pas logé à la même enseigne
et l'an dernier, 2000 communes
ont été privées d'eau potable,
en France, et le scénario
pourrait se répéter en pire.
Maman, j'ai arrêté l'avion.
Générique
...
La sécheresse dans l'Hexagone
pose évidemment la question
du juste partage de l'eau,
de sa gouvernance,
de son stockage et questionne
nos modèles de production,
particulièrement ceux
gourmands en eau.
Comment continuer à produire
dans une France à sec ?
Quels sont les leviers de sobriété ?
Quelles filières soutenir
et quels changements opérer ?
Comment s'adapter
à cet état de sécheresse ?
Pour en débattre, le ministre
de la Transition écologique
et de la Cohésion des territoires.
Bonsoir.
-Bonsoir.
-L'hydroclimatologue
et directrice de recherche
au CNRS, Florence Habets.
-Bonsoir.
-Et le chercheur,
politologue et membre du GIEC,
François Gemenne.
-Bonsoir.
-Merci de venir
participer à l'effort de guerre.
Avant de vous donner
la parole, un état des lieux,
mais quelques chiffres d'abord,
avec notre scientifique.
-L'utilisation domestique
de l'eau représente un quart
de la consommation totale en France,
c'est 148 litres
par personne et par jour.
Le plus gros poste en matière d'eau,
c'est l'agriculture,
qui avale 57 % de l'eau.
Le souci, c'est qu'à cause
du réchauffement climatique,
les ressources nationales
ont diminué de 14 % environ
depuis la fin des années 90,
avec une disparité géographique
et une région sud-ouest
très concernée.
-On l'aura compris,
l'eau nous est comptée.
En France comme ailleurs,
on cherche des solutions,
pour préserver cette ressource
et la répartir au mieux.
Présentées comme la solution
pour continuer à irriguer
en temps de sécheresse,
les bassines d'eau se multiplient
et avec elles,
les points de tension,
comme à Sainte-Soline, où pros
et anti-bassines s'affrontent.
En jeu, 16 réserves de substitution
en cours de chantier.
Voici un reportage d'Alexis Breton
et Jawar Nadi.
On en parle
juste après.
-C'est le début du printemps.
Nous sommes avec le batelier
Julien Leguet,
près de Saint-Hilaire-la-Palud,
à 40 km de La Rochelle
et de la côte atlantique.
Musique légère
Il s'apprête à pigouiller.
-L'instrument que j'utilise,
c'est une pigouille,
c'est facile.
Il y a une espèce
de double pique
qui permet de prendre appui
dans le fond,
sans déraper quand c'est sur du dur,
sans s'enfoncer sur du mou.
-Julien navigue au coeur
des 100 000 hectares
du marais poitevin,
la deuxième plus vaste zone humide
de France après la Camargue.
...
Malgré la beauté
et la sérénité
alentours,
Julien est inquiet.
-Il y a pas âme qui vive.
Il y a pas un poisson
depuis 50 mètres que je pigouille.
J'ai pas un brochet,
j'ai pas vu un gardon.
Il y a rien
de rien.
Il y a pas un herbier.
L'eau est morte.
-L'agro-industrie,
les produits chimiques
qui se déversent dans le marais.
C'est essentiellement en provenance
des terres agricoles alentours.
Et il y a plus de 200 molécules
de pesticides différentes
qui ont été recensées
dans le marais.
-Oiseaux, grenouilles
et autres insectes disparaissent,
et ce n'est peut-être pas le pire.
L'eau déserte
ces zones humides.
-Les marques rouges
qu'on voit là,
c'est le niveau
qui est censé être maintenu en été.
C'est le niveau que l'Etat,
avec les syndicats de propriétaires,
s'engagent à maintenir.
Là, début avril, on est quasiment
10 cm en dessous.
Cette eau qui est partie,
il n'est pas dit qu'une nouvelle
pluie vienne la remplir.
-L'épisode de 32 jours
sans pluie fin janvier
et la très forte sécheresse
de l'été dernier
n'augurent rien de bon.
Pour ce militant
écologiste,
la raréfaction de l'eau
devient le problème numéro 1,
et surtout, ce qui en est
la cause selon lui :
l'accaparement de cette ressource
par l'industrie agricole.
Comme un symbole,
il nous dévoile une autre menace :
le méthane présent dans le sous-sol,
né de la décomposition
des feuilles dans la vase.
-De l'eau jaillit le feu.
-Si ces zones humides s'assèchent,
ce puits sans gaz à effet de serre
sera libéré dans l'atmosphère.
Voilà aussi pourquoi il faut
tout faire pour protéger l'eau.
-C'est un élément vital
dont on dépend tous,
et qui actuellement
est pas respecté
et qui est mis en péril
pour quelques-uns,
et ça génère une forme de feu,
de colère.
-Une colère qui se dirige
aujourd'hui
contre les mégabassines,
ces retenues d'eau gigantesques
construites pour alimenter certaines
exploitations agricoles.
Musique pesante
D'ici à 2025, 16 réservoirs d'eau
géants vont voir le jour
dans la région du marais poitevin.
Des réserves artificielles
capables de stocker à l'air libre
plus de 5 millions
de mètres cubes d'eau.
Le précieux liquide
sera puisé directement
dans la nappe phréatique
qui alimente
les villes et villages
de la région.
C'est le plus grand de ces futurs
lacs artificiels qui cristallise
toutes les oppositions.
Situé sur la commune
de Sainte-Soline,
il s'étendra sur plus
de 10 hectares.
Lieu de manifestation
et d'affrontements depuis un an.
Mégabassines
ou réserves de substitution ?
Symbole de l'agrobusiness
ou réponse à la sécheresse ?
Deux visions s'opposent.
D'un côté, Thierry Boudaud,
l'un des porteurs
du projet bassines,
de l'autre, l'hydrologue
Emma Aziza.
-Si on n'a pas
ces retenues d'eau, à terme,
on est contraints
de supprimer l'irrigation
sur ce territoire,
et on perd la diversité agricole
dont on a besoin.
-Ce qui va se passer
avec ces bassines,
c'est que si on décide construire
le nombre de bassines envisagé,
on va se retrouver
avec encore plus de surfaces
qui vivront des stress hydriques
plus importants et des nappes
qui vont se tarir.
-Dans la campagne niortaise...
...non loin du marais poitevin...
-J'en ai trois.
-...nous avond rendez-vous
dans un camp retranché.
-C'est pas facile
de rentrer ici.
-Et pour cause : devenant l'enjeu
de beaucoup de contestations
et de beaucoup d'interrogations,
il nous a fallu protéger ce site
tel un fort en plein désert.
-Philippe Mauffray est le maire
de Mauzé-sur-le-Mignon,
une commune de 3000 âmes qui abrite
un trésor qu'il faut protéger...
-Fort Knox.
...
-...de l'or bleu
en grande quantité.
-On est toujours
à Mauzé-sur-le-Mignon
et non pas à Mauzé-sur-mer,
et vous avez en face de vous
l'étendue qui représente
241 000 mètres cubes
sur 27,5 hectares
de surface au sol.
-Voilà ce qu'eux appellent
réserve de substitution.
Construite en hauteur,
à base de sable et de béton,
son fon est recouvert
d'une bâche en PVC
afin de conserver l'eau issue
de la nappe phréatique,
qui va permettre d'irriguer
l'été prochain
cinq exploitations voisines
grâce à des tuyaux enterrés.
-A Mauzé-sur-le-Mignon,
je perds l'élevage, la culture,
je n'ai plus rien.
J'ai quelques sociétés
qui sont là
dans la périphérie, mais néanmoins,
le plus important pour moi,
c'est cette économie liée
à l'agriculture.
Le dernier été,
on a vu, quand même,
l'extrême chaleur
que nous avons eue,
donc il faut maintenant commencer
à imaginer l'avenir
et faire des réserves d'eau.
-Pour cela, monsieur le maire
et les agriculteurs du coin
n'ont pas hésité à dépenser beaucoup
d'argent, notamment celui de l'Etat.
Cette réserve a coûté
2,5 millions d'euros,
dont 70 % de subventions publiques.
Qui a payé pour les barbelés
et autres caméras anti-intrusion ?
Une alarme retentit.
...
On ne le saura pas.
Une chose est sûre,
le maire est convaincu
du bienfondé du projet.
-L'eau, par principe,
quand elle est là,
c'est quand elle est en excès.
Donc on la réserve
pour les moments difficiles.
J'ai bien dit,
lorsque les épisodes pluvieux
sont nombreux
et qu'ils nous apportent
cette quantité d'eau,
on la met de côté.
Quand vous touchez
un petit héritage,
vous faites des placements.
On fait pareil.
-En aucun cas, on peut dire
qu'aller piocher de l'eau
dans une nappe phréatique
est une solution,
et encore plus
avec de nouvelles conditions
qui arrivent en France,
où on n'a plus de pluie l'hiver.
En fait, la nappe phréatique,
c'est le moyen facile de pouvoir
produire toujours plus,
chercher toujours plus d'eau,
quitte à ce qu'on la pille
complètement, cette nappe,
à ce qu'on la détruise.
-L'adversité
du changement climatique,
on la mesure, elle va être telle
qu'il faut utiliser
tous les leviers
à notre disposition.
Il faut planter des haies,
faire des retenues d'eau collectives
mais avoir un partage de l'eau,
c'est indispensable.
-Le partage, c'est justement
une partie du problème.
L'eau des bassines, bien publique,
ne va bénéficier directement
qu'à un petit nombre d'agriculteurs,
une petite partie
des exploitants irrigants
de la coopération de l'eau
des Deux-Sèvres.
Assiste-t-on alors
à une privatisation
d'une ressource vitale ?
Réponse à quelques
kilomètres
de la réserve
de Mauzé-sur-le-Mignon.
François Pétorin prépare son champ
pour les futurs semis.
Il fait partie des militants
pour la construction des bassines.
-C'est vraiment indispensable.
On a des sols très superficiels.
Les cultures ont besoin d'eau,
que ce soit au printemps
ou en été,
et les blés tendres aussi,
au mois de mai-juin,
en fonction
de la climato.
Ils ont besoin d'eau
pour remplir le grain.
Donc c'est vital pour le territoire,
pour l'agriculture.
-François cultive
principalement des céréales
sur une exploitation
de 200 hectares.
L'année prochaine,
il sera raccordé à une bassine
encore en construction.
-Aujourd'hui,
le projet, sur les 16 réserves
qui sont prévues,
c'est 220 exploitations,
mais ça représente
450 agriculteurs au total,
sur l'ensemble du territoire,
de Sainte-Soline
à Mauzé-sur-le-Mignon.
On a un volume attribué
par l'Etat.
Donc l'eau n'appartient
à personne.
Il y a pas de privatisation
ou d'accaparement,
comme il peut être dit.
-On peut affirmer que ce n'est pas
une privatisation de l'eau,
mais il n'y a pas d'autre terme.
Si vous prenez de l'eau et que
vous la conservez pour vos usages
au détriment des autres,
c'est une privatisation.
Le problème, c'est qu'on va
de plus en plus être
face à des économies
qui vont se confronter.
Le milieu énergétique,
qui a besoin de quantités d'eau,
nos robinets ont besoin d'eau,
notre humanité en a besoin.
Donc on voit à quel point
il va falloir
faire des choix, et c'est l'enjeu
qu'on a actuellement,
et ces frictions.
-On n'est pas dans un projet
où c'est un club fermé
d'agriculteurs qui avaient
des droits historiques
qui peuvent irriguer demain,
c'est exactement l'inverse :
en fait, le territoire
décide tous les ans
d'une répartition de l'eau
et il faut
que l'accès à l'eau
pour tous les agriculteurs
qui le demandent soit le même.
-Ce qu'il oublie de nous dire,
c'est que seuls 6 % des agriculteurs
seraient raccordés
en l'état actuel du projet.
Les autres devront compter
sur des nappes suffisamment
chargées l'été
pour pouvoir irriguer.
Comment s'est fait la répartition ?
Les adeptes de l'agriculture
productiviste
sont-ils favorisés ?
A Vançais, Rémi Laurendeau
est un petit maraîcher qui cultive
des légumes bio sur trois hectares.
-Elles ont pas gelé.
Super.
Des patates primeur.
On va en avoir
la semaine prochaine.
-Sur ses terres,
il fait très attention
à sa consommation en eau.
-Le goutte-à-goutte,
c'est un système tout simple.
De l'eau à basse pression
passe dedans.
Le tuyau est perforé
tous les 20 cm.
Donc là, on a une perte de l'eau
qui est très faible,
pour un rendu super.
C'est du 90 % utilisable
par la plante.
-Comme François,
Rémi est lui aussi membre
de la coopérative de l'eau
et finance une petite partie
des travaux des bassines,
mais contrairement
à son collègue céréalier,
le maraîcher a vu sa demande
de raccordement ignorée.
-J'avais demandé en 2019
un raccordement
à un projet de bassine
sur une autre commune.
Et ma lettre est restée
sans réponse pendant deux ans.
Il faut savoir
que vu mon faible volume,
ça coûterait trop cher,
et je le comprends,
à la collectivité
donc à la coop' de l'eau.
Ce serait pas rentable
de me raccorder.
-Pas de raccordement,
et une grande peur.
Musique pesante
-La ressource en eau
de mon exploitation.
C'est un puits,
il est très peu profond.
On voit l'eau, là.
-Son puits plonge dans la même
nappe phréatique
que la plus célèbre
des mégabassines.
-Sainte-Soline,
c'est avant mon puits.
C'est les mêmes sources.
Ma crainte, c'est que mon puits
soit à sec.
J'avais demandé des garanties,
et j'en n'ai pas.
Si je n'ai plus d'eau,
je ne peux plus irriguer
et je n'ai plus de légumes
ni d'exploitation.
-Un problème que n'auront pas
les plus gros producteurs,
ceux qui font pousser du blé,
du maïs, du colza et de la betterave
à coups de pesticide
et de centaines de milliers
de mètres cubes d'eau.
-On confronte, effectivement,
un système agroalimentaire intensif,
qui a besoin de beaucoup d'eau,
face à des ruraux
qui sont aussi
des maraîchers locaux.
Je crois que Sainte-Soline
est à l'image
de ces modèles confrontés.
-Souvenez-vous,
c'était le 25 mars.
Le gigantesque
rassemblement non autorisé
contre la non moins gigantesque
construction de Sainte-Soline :
des milliers de manifestants
convergent vers la mégabassine
de la discorde.
Klaxons et cris de joie
Parmi eux, l'amoureux du marais
poitevin, le porte-parole
du collectif anti-bassine,
Julien Leguet.
-Il y a une soixantaine
de tracteurs.
Rien que ça, c'est une image
très forte.
Ca veut dire
que c'est les paysans
et le peuple contre
l'agro-industrie.
C'est fini, ce système,
place à la vie.
No pasaran.
Cris de joie
-Sous contrôle judiciaire
pour avoir notamment organisé
des manifestations
sans autorisation,
il a l'interdiction
de se rendre sur la commune
de Sainte-Soline.
La bassine, un simple trou
pour le moment,
est protégée par des centaines
de gendarmes.
Propos indistincts au loin
-La bataille de Sainte-Soline :
deux camps face-à-face
pour deux visions
irréconciliables.
Un modèle productif
qui a fait ses preuves
et qui assure la souveraineté
alimentaire du pays
pour les uns, pour les autres,
un modèle industriel
qui refuse toute idée
de changement et de sobriété
et qui entraîne la France
vers la catastrophe.
-La guerre de l'eau m'a tout l'air
d'avoir commencé, non ?
-En tout cas,
on a une crispation
particulièrement forte
dans un endroit très spécial,
ciblé dans un reportage,
un lieu qui a fait
la une de l'actualité,
pour informer tout le monde,
mais on peut pas résumer
ni ce que serait la stratégie
de l'eau à l'échelle du pays
à ce qui se passe
dans un département
ni résumer ce qui serait
le modèle souhaitable
à quelques échanges qui ont eu lieu.
Je veux dire les choses
de manière claire.
Il n'y a aucune alternative
à la sobriété.
On aura moins d'eau.
Se dire qu'on va trouver
des méthodes pour continuer à faire
comme si on pouvait en avoir autant,
c'est impossible.
Il n'y a pas de meilleures retenues
que les nappes phréatiques.
Une fois que j'ai dit ça
et que j'ai posé
ces principes qui sont
réellement la base
de toute la réflexion
qu'on doit être capables
de conduire,
on est sur un bout de territoire
avec ses particularités,
avec un accord entre la gauche,
qui gère la région,
la droite, le département...
-Ces bassines
sont controversées ailleurs.
-Oui, mais là-bas,
où on en discute
de manière particulière,
on exacerbe les tensions
compte tenu de leurs
dimensions hors-normes...
-Des tensions
en Haute-Savoie.
-Il y a les retenues
qui prennent de l'eau de pluie
qui sont moins controversées
parce qu'on comprend...
-On va en parler
avec Florence Habets.
-...et le système, là,
qui interroge
l'opinion publique.
On pompe dans une nappe
qui est censée
permettre de préserver les choses
pour le mettre
dans une bassine à l'air libre.
Le point
de rencontre,
c'est qu'on est
sur un sous-sol karstique,
qui ne retient pas l'eau,
ce qui explique les études
favorables à cette réalisation
et qu'on ait des décisions
de justice favorables
à ce projet, parce qu'on a
ces caractéristiques.
Enfin, malgré le caractère
bucolique du reportage...
-Oui...
-Je tiens juste
à rappeler en 15 secondes
que si la manifestation
a été interdite, c'est pas parce que
le débat est impossible,
mais parce qu'au mois d'octobre,
plus de 60 gendarmes ont été blessés
et qu'au milieu de ceux qui,
légitimement,
peuvent considérer qu'il faut aller
vers un autre type
d'agriculture,
on a des gens qui sont venus
spécifiquement pour blesser
des gendarmes.
La manifestation a été interdite
compte tenu des craintes
et elles ont été avérées
avec des affrontements
qui n'ont rien
d'une balade en forêt.
-François Gemenne,
vous êtes d'accord
avec Christophe Béchu ?
les anti-bassines sont venus
pour casser du gendarme ?
-Non, c'est pas spécialement
les anti-bassines.
Aujourd'hui, dans toutes
les manifestations,
que ce soient les bassines,
la réforme des retraites, etc.,
vous avez des gens
qui viennent
pour frapper des gendarmes,
des policiers,
et on est dans une logique
de surenchère
dans le maintien de l'ordre
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui,
certains ont peur de manifester.
Ce n'est pas possible en démocratie.
Le droit de manifester
est fondamental.
-Pour bien comprendre,
vous les jugez pertinentes,
ces mégabassines, à l'heure
de la hausse des températures
en France ?
Ce sont des chiffres
que vous avez annoncés :
+ 2,5 degrés en 2030,
+ 3 degrés en 2050,
+4 degrés en 2100.
Pour bien comprendre,
est-ce que vous pensez
que ces mégabassines
sont pertinentes
malgré la hausse
des températures ?
-C'est la vraie question.
Elles ont été validées
dans un contexte
qui était des modèles,
les seuls dont on dispose,
qui consistent à projeter
ce que sera la ressource disponible
compte tenu d'une augmentation
des températures
basée sur un + 2 degrés.
Dans le plan
que nous avons présenté,
nous allons actualiser,
d'ici la fin de l'année,
les prévisions
pour intégrer la perspective
non pas d'une France
qui se réchauffe de 2 degrés,
mais qui se réchauffe
jusqu'à 4 degrés,
ce que j'ai eu l'occasion de dire.
C'est-à-dire modifier
les modèles et les références
qui permettent au BRGM
de faire ses projections.
Un des axes de critiques...
-Ca n'a pas été le cas
pour ces mégabassines.
-Ca l'a été sur la base...
-De 2006, 2011.
-Exactement.
-Sans tenir compte
du réchauffement climatique.
-Si.
-Non, non.
-Non, le BRGM
ne l'a pas pris en compte.
C'est lui qui le dit.
-Il dit que c'est basé
sur les chiffres de 2006 à 2011.
Le nouveau modèle
qui prend en compte ces 4 degrés
s'établit. Il sera disponible
à la fin de l'année.
On ne peut pas reprocher...
-Aucune étude avec le BRGM
n'a été faite, dans le contexte
de Sainte-Soline,
avec le changement climatique.
-Ca a été fait avec le changement
climatique à 1,5 degrés.
-J'ai discuté
avec les modélisateurs,
et la réponse était non.
-Je ne peux pas
vous laisser dire ça.
Si vous reprenez,
les études ont été faites
sur la base des données
de 2006 à 2011.
Nous sommes en train,
en ce moment, de doter le BRGM
en fin d'année
de ce nouveau modèle,
Explore 2, qui permet
de faire des projections
avec des températures plus élevées.
-Je connais ce projet.
C'est un des loupés
de cette concertation de la COP 79,
d'avoir rassemblé
tous les agriculteurs
d'un territoire
pour discuter du partage de l'eau.
Ca, c'était super.
Pour quand même régler
un problème qui était antérieur,
bien antérieur à ça,
une sur-irrigation
dans les années 90
qui ont vraiment mis en péril
la ressource en eau
de la région
avec des étiages très marqués.
C'est pour résoudre
un problème ancien que ces bassines
ont été pensées,
mais elles ont été pensées
sans le changement climatique.
C'est le risque de la maladaptation.
Vous le savez,
pour s'adapter
au changement climatique,
le poids de l'héritage
est un problème,
le fait qu'on dispose
d'équipements
qui, finalement,
imposent des stratégies
pour finalement
rentabiliser tout ça.
Aujourd'hui,
investir de nouveau,
renforcer cette dépendance
à une irrigation intensive,
c'est ça,
la question qui se pose.
-Il a un consensus scientifique
autour de ces réserves d'eau
pour dire
que ce n'est pas une solution.
Elles appauvrissent les sols ?
Elles aggravent la sécheresse ?
-En fait, ces bassines-là,
toutes ces retenues
qui sont dédiées à l'irrigation,
visent à permettre une irrigation
qui est souvent coûteuse,
donc on demande
des rendements importants.
Elles ne sont pas là
pour sécuriser,
comme on l'entend parfois.
"Sécuriser", ça veut dire :
"Je n'utilise cette eau
que quand j'en ai besoin,
"c'est-à-dire rarement."
Là, on n'est pas dans ce contexte.
On va optimiser une ressource
aujourd'hui,
dans un temps présent :
dès qu'il y aura une sécheresse,
j'aurais quand même tout consommé,
et pour autant,
je serais peut-être incapable
de produire. L'été dernier,
il y a eu de l'irrigation du maïs
dans le sud-ouest,
mais pas de production,
à cause des échaudages.
Déjà, en temps présent,
mais demain,
c'est encore plus clivant.
Pourquoi on pense
que ce n'est pas
la bonne solution ?
Non pas que ce ne soit
pas partie de la solution,
mais il ne faut pas baser
toute la solution...
-C'est exactement
ce que je dis.
-Mais les conditions climatiques
de demain imposeront sans doute
que pour produire
un peu de rendement,
il faudra peut-être que plus de gens
aient accès à l'eau,
et ça repose donc tout à fait
le partage d'eau,
ce en quoi l'Etat
a toute sa place.
-C'est la question
avec les températures
du type de culture.
C'est la question des sols.
C'est y compris la question
des temporalités :
il nous arrive d'avoir
des productions l'hiver
plus consommatrices en eau,
mais en hiver,
en automne, on ne manque pas d'eau.
-Ca dépend.
-Je le dis à dessein
compte tenu
de l'hiver qu'on a vécu,
et du fait qu'on repose
sur des certitudes.
La commande a été passée
d'avoir des trajectoires
en intégrant
le réchauffement climatique,
pas un petit comme celui
qu'on anticipait
il y a 30 ans,
mais la réalité
de ce que toutes
les études scientifiques disent :
on ne fera pas l'économie.
Quand ce nouveau modèle
de projection sortira,
de refaire tourner
une partie des hypothèses
une partie des projets, sur la base
de ces nouvelles projections.
-A-t-on besoin
de ces projections
pour réaliser que le modèle
est déjà caduc, y compris
dans cette région-là ?
-Je ne vais pas vous expliquer
que j'ai beaucoup d'humilité
devant les scientifiques
sur un certain nombre de domaines.
Si nous faisons travailler le BRGM,
mais pas seulement,
l'INRA, Météo France,
c'est parce qu'il y a des choses
qu'on sait,
et il y a une part d'humidité.
Il faut savoir croiser
les connaissances,
et j'attends la conclusion
des experts pour avoir...
-Pour vous, c'est trop dur
de prendre la décision ?
-Non, ce que je veux dire,
c'est que ce sera l'aide
à la décision. Je le répète :
nous aurons moins d'eau
disponible...
-Beaucoup moins d'eau.
-Entre 10 et 40 %
en fonction des secteurs
sur lesquels on se trouve.
La sobriété
est la seule solution
dont on dispose à moyen terme,
et les nappes sont
notre urgence.
Ca peut paraître décalé,
mais la lutte
contre l'artificialisation,
l'étalement urbain,
la perméabilisation des sols ruraux,
c'est aussi important
que de discuter des parties rurales
et des types de culture.
Tout est lié.
-On va parler de sobriété.
La gestion de l'eau,
on l'aura compris,
est un enjeu majeur.
On se souvient tous
peu ou prou
de nos cours de biologie
sur le cycle de l'eau,
cycle que l'agriculture,
par ses pratiques intensives,
perturbe,
mais l'eau bleue
n'est pas la seule
à être touchée.
Il y a aussi l'eau verte.
Vous allez nous rafraîchir
la mémoire.
C'est l'heure du Climatoscope
et c'est à vous.
-Je vais revenir d'abord
sur le cycle général de l'eau.
On sait,
on se souvient à peu près tous,
que les océans injectent
beaucoup d'eau
dans l'atmosphère,
que la masse d'air humide
monte, se refroidit,
et éjecte des molécules d'eau
qui donnent des gouttes,
et qui vont retomber
sur les reliefs, et donner lieu
à un ruissellement
qui donne les ruisseaux,
les rivières, les fleuves,
puis retournent dans l'océan.
Maintenant, quand on voit couler
la rivière au fond de son jardin,
ou la Seine sous le pont Mirabeau,
on a l'impression
que tout va bien.
-Pourtant, ce n'est pas le cas.
-Non.
C'est au moins une illusion
car quand on ne regarde
que le niveau des lacs
et des rivières,
on ne fait pas attention
au cycle de l'eau verte :
toute l'eau qui tombe
ne retourne pas dans les océans.
Quand il pleut,
l'eau imprègne les sols.
Une partie s'infiltre
dans les nappes phréatiques,
et l'autre partie
est absorbée par les plantes
qui, par les racines,
vont réinjecter l'eau
dans les airs, puis transpirent
de gros volumes d'eau
qui vont participer
aux précipitations.
C'est le cycle de l'eau verte.
On a réalisé,
l'an dernier notamment
à travers
une publication,
que ce cycle ne va pas
très bien.
-C'est un euphémisme.
-Oui, ne va pas bien.
-Disons-le.
-Les scientifiques ont évalué
l'humidité des sols
dans plusieurs de pays
et ils constatent
que sur 1/5 de ces terres,
les teneurs en eau sont anormales
par rapport au passé,
et à un tel niveau
que les scientifiques parlent
d'une nouvelle limite franchie
comme le réchauffement climatique,
la biodiversité,
la pollution chimique,
ou l'érosion.
Or, on sait que ce cycle
de l'eau verte est perturbé
par l'artificialisation des sols,
l'expansion urbaine,
la déforestation
et l'agriculture intensive.
Ces 4 phénomènes
empêchent le sol
de retenir l'humidité,
ce qui accélère l'aridification
via la hausse des températures,
ce qui constitue un cercle vicieux.
-Ce n'est pas sans conséquences.
-Ca peut aboutir à une modification
de la répartition de l'eau
sur des continents entiers.
Un exemple frappant,
c'est la déforestation en Amazonie.
L'Amazonie,
on la voit comme le poumon vert
de la planète.
Ce qu'on oublie,
c'est que c'est aussi
une énorme fontaine d'eau.
Un grand arbre en Amazonie
peut injecter
jusqu'à 1000 l d'eau
dans l'atmosphère,
donc le bilan
est absolument énorme.
Les volumes d'eau
qui circulent dans l'air
sont plus importants
que le débit du fleuve Amazone
qui est le plus grand du monde.
Les scientifiques parlent
de "rivière volante".
Ces rivières volantes
vont arroser
la totalité du continent
de l'Amérique du Sud.
La vie de millions de gens
dépend de cette eau
qui vient irriguer leurs sols.
On a donc un point très important
sur le cycle de l'eau verte,
qui est en train de basculer,
nous disent les scientifiques.
-La question qui se pose,
c'est le juste partage
de cette eau.
L'agriculture irriguée
ne représente que 7,3 %
de la surface agricole en France
qui est surtout destinée
à produire du maïs
pour l'alimentation animale
et pour l'exportation.
Ceux qui prétendent
que notre souveraineté alimentaire
est menacée et dépend
de ces bassines
se moquent de nous ?
-Déjà, c'était intéressant
de replacer le contexte
en 15 secondes
à l'échelle mondiale.
La population de la planète
augmente,
les ressources diminuent,
et on réalise que les problèmes
qu'on a chez nous
prennent, à l'échelle
de sous-continents mondiaux,
des proportions incroyables.
Aujourd'hui,
il y a certains pays
qui montent des barrages.
On parle de retenu
sur un cycle de l'eau,
mais ils montent des barrages
qui se comptent
en dizaine de millions de m3
et qui pourraient entraîner
demain d'importants
déplacements de population.
A cette échelle, finalement,
la souveraineté alimentaire
regroupe deux aspects.
Aura-t-on de quoi nourrir
une population qui approche
des 10 milliards d'habitants
alors que partout,
il faudra faire avec moins ?
Et comment on ne prend pas
des décisions hypocrites
dans un pays qui se traduiraient
forcément par l'augmentation
de nos exportations ?
On a des marges d'amélioration
considérables dans l'agriculture.
Il n'y a pas d'agriculture
sans eau.
-7,3. 7,3.
-On a moins de 10 % des terres
irriguées avec des systèmes
de goutte-à-goutte
qui sont économes,
des pratiques en termes de culture
où on ne fait pas attention
aux horaires
auxquels on va irriguer,
et donc on génère
de la sur-évaporation.
-L'été passé, les céréaliers
irriguaient par 30 degrés,
sous le cagnard,
en pleine journée,
des cultures. C'est aberrant
quand on parle de sobriété.
-Quand j'évoquais la question
de la nature des sols
et des températures pour modifier
les trajectoires d'agriculture,
c'est aussi ce qui nous attend.
On a, globalement, l'amélioration
de l'hydraulique agricole,
l'amélioration
des techniques d'irrigation,
mais je reviens à la sobriété
et au fait qu'on est face
à des phénomènes où penser
qu'on sera plus fort que la nature,
c'est une folie.
Le sujet, c'est comment assurer
cette transition.
Entre les deux, les agriculteurs
le font pour nous nourrir,
pour assurer un dispositif
où, à la fin, si c'est encore
pour augmenter nos importations,
on n'améliore
ni la situation de la planète,
ni la situation hydrique globale.
-Ce n'est pas vrai.
Vous savez que le maïs
qui est utilisé
pour l'alimentation animale
nécessite
l'importation de soja,
donc on est aussi
dans cette impasse que vous avez
mentionnée à la dernière émission
qui était sur l'alimentation.
-Si vous continuez à dézoomer
et que vous ajoutez la totalité,
il n'y a pas seulement
la position française,
mais aussi les stratégies
d'autres pays,
les accords de libre-échange
qu'on a montés en considérant
que ça permettrait
à d'autres populations
de sortir de la pauvreté.
On peut faire comme si une décision
en France, à Paris,
à quelques semaines de l'été
pouvait tout bouleverser,
mais avec un peu d'humilité,
on peut ensuite relier ces enjeux.
-10 millions d'euros
ont été débloqués
par le gouvernement,
soit 166 euros par ferme
pour le bio
toute filière confondue
contre un enveloppe
de 270 millions l'an passé,
juste pour la filière porc.
Vous considérez que c'est juste,
quand aujourd'hui
nous sommes en situation
de stress hydrique
et qu'il faudrait soutenir
avant tout, dites-nous,
l'agroforesterie
et l'agroécologie ?
-Me proposer des chiffres
comme ça dans un contexte
où je suis ravi de participer
cette polyphonie et de défendre seul
un certain nombre
de positions...
Bon... Je voudrais remettre
les choses à leur place.
Typiquement, y compris dans le plan
qui vient d'être présenté,
les crédits les plus importants
sont pour la conversion au bio
et l'agroécologie.
C'est 200 millions d'euros annuels
indépendamment des crédits
de soutien aux filières
qui existaient déjà auparavant.
-Vouloir s'adapter à la sécheresse
en exonérant de tout effort
le plus gros
consommateur agricole
ne serait-ce pas contradictoire ?
-C'est, je dirais,
un exemple type
de ce qu'on appelle
la maladaptation :
des solutions d'adaptation
qui soit vont essayer
de résoudre un problème immédiat
mais vont compromettre
les capacités
d'adaptation dans le futur,
donc un emplâtre
sur une jambe de bois...
C'est ce qui se passe
avec les mégabassines !
On comprend les agriculteurs
quand ils disent :
"Si je n'irrigue pas mes cultures,
je vais devoir fermer boutique",
mais ça risque de compromettre
nos capacités d'adaptation
dans le futur, et ça,
c'est un enjeu fondamental.
En s'accrochant
à des modèles agricoles du passé
qui sont très dépendants
de l'irrigation,
on tire une balle
dans le pied
des agriculteurs,
parce que sur le long terme,
on ne garantira pas
la pérennité de l'agriculture
ni des revenus décents
pour des agriculteurs
qui sont en souffrance
pour la plupart.
L'autre enjeu,
c'est évidemment la question
du partage de la ressource
et des conflits d'usage.
D'un coup,
une ressource
qu'on croyait abondante
et pour laquelle
on ne se posait pas
la question du partage
avec des abus parfois aberrants
sur l'irrigation,
eh bien d'un coup, cette ressource
devient de plus en plus limitée,
et donc,
on va avoir des conflits
de plus en plus violents
comme celui qu'on a vu
à Sainte-Soline
sur cette question, précisément,
de l'allocation
d'une ressource rare.
Ca va être le cas pour l'eau,
ça va être le cas pour les terres
et ça va surtout être le cas
pour la question du carbone.
Qui a le droit d'utiliser
quel budget carbone,
dans un contexte où il va falloir
réduire drastiquement
notre empreinte carbone ?
-Votre opinion,
M. Béchu ?
-Je suis d'accord,
mais on a un discours décorrélé
de la réalité.
On prend un exemple
dans un coin de France
sur la base
d'un protocole de 2018
sur lequel
il y a plein de choses à dire,
et on fait comme si la stratégie
était celle d'une maladaptation,
alors qu'on a expliqué
que tout le monde doit faire
des efforts...
-Non, le secteur agricole...
Pardonnez-moi,
votre homologue à l'Agriculture,
Marc Fesneau, a dit
que la filière agricole
n'aurait aucun effort supplémentaire
à faire.
-Je vous assure
que dans les propos qu'il a tenus,
il a expliqué que la part
qui était dévolue à l'agriculture...
-Serait la même.
-Non, allait diminuer à l'hectare !
Ce sont ses propos
lors de la conférence de presse,
au lendemain
de la présentation du plan eau.
La part globale pour l'agriculture
ne va pas varier en pourcentage,
mais elle va bien diminuer
en tendance...
-Vous l'avez entendu aussi ?
-J'ai compris qu'il n'y avait pas
d'effort demandé à l'agriculture.
Ca a été présenté comme ça.
Effectivement...
-Alors, ça a été maladroit.
-On a tous compris ça.
-Ce n'est pas possible
d'avoir une baisse
des prélèvements
et de la consommation,
ça n'existe pas.
-On a tous compris ça.
-Je vous assure...
-Les agriculteurs,
donc, vont faire un effort ?
-Cette filière,
elle n'est ni aveugle ni sourde.
-Mais de façon contraignante ?
-Mais comment voulez-vous
qu'on fasse autrement ?
Le débat,
c'est entre la "pureté scientifique"
qui explique
qu'il faut tout changer demain matin
et le fait qu'on a en face de nous
des personnes,
des investissements,
une réalité,
qui nécessitent
de concevoir ces transitions.
-Vous savez que le prix
de l'inaction va être terrible ?
-Je dis pas qu'on n'agit pas.
Pour la première fois
depuis 20 ans...
Qu'on me donne des précédents
de ce qui a été fait
en matière de gestion de l'eau,
de sobriété, depuis 20 ans ?
On est en train de construire
une gouvernance nouvelle
par rapport au passé.
-Je crois que c'est dans l'intérêt
des agriculteurs.
-Bien entendu !
-Si on ne fait pas évoluer
les modèles
en vue du changement climatique,
on condamne les agriculteurs,
non seulement
car ils n'auront plus de rendement,
mais surtout car ils vont devoir
mettre des barbelés
autour de leurs cultures,
comme on l'a vu dans le reportage.
On fait pas de l'agriculture
en camp retranché.
C'est pas possible, ni pour eux,
ni pour les opposants.
-Un mot sur la qualité de l'eau.
90 % des cours d'eau
et des rivières
sont contaminés aux pesticides.
Un tiers de l'eau
a été pollué par un pesticide,
le Syngenta, utilisé depuis 1970
et interdit en 2019.
Ces contaminations sont massives,
mais Emmanuel Macron n'en a pas eu
un mot dans son plan eau.
-Vous avez un volet sur la qualité
qui regroupe une dizaine de mesures,
et qui repose sur le fait
qu'on mette en place
un plan de gestion
sur la sécurité sanitaire
des eaux pour chaque captage.
On explique que les préfets
prendront des mesures automatiques
de fermeture.
Au cours de ces dernières années,
pour des dépassements de seuil...
-4300 captages d'eau fermés
en France.
-Exactement.
-C'est énorme.
-Mais c'est à la hauteur du chiffre
que vous n'avez pas donné :
43 % de nos masses d'eau,
au sens large,
sont considérées de bonne qualité.
-Alors, que répondez-vous
à votre homologue,
Marc Fesneau,
qui veut repousser l'interdiction
de l'herbicide S-métolachlore,
en France, utilisé pour lutter
contre les mauvaises herbes,
mais accusé de polluer
les nappes phréatiques
et, accessoirement,
qui a été classé en juin 2022
comme cancérogène probable.
On marche sur la tête !
-Il n'y a pas de contradiction
sur le fait
d'expliquer la nécessité
d'aller interdire,
mais de manière européenne.
Et sur ce type de questions,
pour éviter
qu'on se retrouve avec des écarts
qui alimentent l'hypocrisie...
Si j'interdis un produit,
mais que je l'ingère,
car je l'importe depuis l'Italie,
l'Allemagne ou la Belgique,
je vais faire croire au consommateur
qu'on l'a sécurisé...
Dans ce domaine,
ce que la Première ministre
a annoncé,
c'est que, dans le cadre
du nouveau plan Ecophyto,
nous allons prendre les produits
qui vont être interdits
pour construire les alternatives.
On marche sur la tête.
On attend d'avoir un avis négatif...
-Je suis ravie de l'entendre.
-Je le pense.
-Non, mais très bien.
-Puisque ce truc est interdit,
on imagine une alternative.
Quand elle sera prête,
l'interdiction sera effective.
-L'alternative ultime,
c'est le bio, quand même.
-L'enjeu,
c'est d'aller modifier le process
et c'est de se dire :
OK, par rapport à des calendriers
d'interdiction souhaitable,
il faut rechercher
les alternatives.
-Pourquoi pas directement le bio ?
On sait bien que, finalement,
le bio permet
de se passer de ces pesticides
et donc conserve
une bonne qualité de l'eau,
et il y avait un objectif,
à une époque...
-Et une qualité des sols.
-...d'arriver à au moins 15 %
de surfaces en bio en France.
On n'en est pas là,
et le bio régresse.
Pourquoi il n'y a pas
cet effort vers le bio ?
-La transition vers le bio,
là aussi, je rejoins ce que disait
François Gemenne,
elle est en train d'être adoptée
par la profession.
On a un effet de recul
sur lequel on travaille,
car à cause du contexte
d'inflation élevée,
des gens s'en sont détournés
pour des raisons budgétaires,
alors qu'en termes de qualité,
on voit bien
l'impact et l'intérêt.
A la fin, on est
dans un système d'économie ouvert
où du bio
qui vient du bout du monde,
il est moins souhaitable
que du local qui vient de proximité.
Pour avoir, dans un passé récent,
géré une cantine,
à l'échelle d'une collectivité,
vous mesurez
dans un certain nombre de cas
que vous ne pouvez pas résumer
l'empreinte écologique d'un produit
au fait de savoir
s'il est bio.
La question de sa provenance
et de sa production
comptent...
-Par endroits,
des maraîchers bios
n'ont pas accès à l'eau...
Il n'y a pas des priorités d'usage
à mettre aussi ?
-Mais encore une fois...
Je suis ravi d'être comptable
de tout ce qui se passe dans ce pays
ou de tout
ce qui ne s'est pas passé.
Ce que je dis...
-Vous êtes en exercice,
monsieur le ministre.
C'est difficile.
-J'ai compris.
Ce que je vous dis...
-C'est ingrat.
-Le mot de transition a un sens.
Vous l'avez très bien dit,
pendant des décennies, on a vécu
dans une telle illusion d'abondance
que nous n'avons pas regardé
les réformes cohérentes
qu'il fallait qu'on conduise.
Quand on doit les faire,
on a des tensions,
des agriculteurs qui ont bloqué
une route nationale pour protester
contre des interdictions
ou des diminutions d'autorisation
de prélèvement
dans les Pyrénées-Orientales,
où on a des communes
qui n'ont pas d'eau potable,
début du mois d'avril,
et où on a eu le 1er grand incendie
de ce début d'année.
C'est pas le gouvernement qui dit
"on va faire une restriction",
c'est juste le constat
que sans ressources,
on ne va pas autoriser...
-Mais les violences
vont se répéter.
Si le bio est une solution,
on en a une pour vous.
Ici, à Grenoble, on n'attend pas
d'être au pied du mur
pour investir
dans l'habitat de demain.
On se loge en étant presque
autonome en eau et en énergie.
La preuve en images,
signées Alexis Breton
et Xavier Luizet.
-Grenoble, à deux pas du Vercors
et au beau milieu
des Alpes françaises.
158 240 âmes, c'est précis,
et parmi elles,
quelques dizaines d'habitants
un peu particuliers, des cobayes,
qui vivent dans ces deux immeubles
aux allures de station spatiale.
Des volontaires
pour la bonne cause : pour l'eau,
comme Alexandre,
un enseignant chercheur de 31 ans...
-J'arrivais pas à trouver.
-...et Anne,
sa voisine à la retraite,
qui vient boire une petite infusion
à l'eau de pluie,
qui coule pourtant du robinet.
-C'est de l'eau de pluie d'hier,
par exemple.
Alors, il y a de l'eau de la ville,
il y a de l'eau qui est potabilisée,
et ils mélangent les deux.
-20 % d'eau de pluie,
20 % d'eau recyclée
et 60 % d'eau municipale,
pour être exact.
-Ca fait 3 ans que vous buvez
de l'eau de pluie.
-Exactement, et ça se voit, non ?
J'ai pas un très beau teint ?
Presque un teint de rose.
-Et le goût, alors ?
-Ca n'a pas un goût particulier,
ça n'a pas de goût marqué.
Je bois toujours
de l'eau du robinet.
Il n'y a pas de goût.
C'est vrai que certains voisins
se sont plaints du goût de l'eau,
par moments.
Moi, j'ai jamais rien remarqué.
-Moi non plus.
-Comme tous les locataires,
ils expérimentent
une gestion de l'eau innovante,
un test grandeur nature de 5 ans
pour diminuer
la consommation d'eau des Français :
148 litres par personne
et par jour.
Dans la douche,
un dispositif particulier indique
les litres consommés.
-Au début, c'est vert.
A partir de 10 litres,
le pommeau va
se colorer en bleu,
puis à partir de 30 litres,
en violet,
puis à 40, en rouge.
Et là, donc voilà,
on a plus que 10 litres,
et jusqu'à 20 litres,
ça va faire du bleu.
-Des économies d'eau
qui vont au-delà
des recommandations de l'ADEME,
qui suggère de ne pas dépasser
une douche de 5 minutes,
soit en moyenne 50 litres d'eau.
-Le but,
c'est de pas dépasser le bleu,
et c'est vraiment
pas compliqué, quoi.
Et en été, c'est la verte,
et je la dépasse pas.
-Seul problème
dans cet appartement :
Alexandre ne peut pas boire l'eau
de ses toilettes.
-Il y en a pas besoin,
à cet endroit-là,
d'eau potable, justement.
L'eau vient de notre douche
ou de notre lavabo,
et après, elle part en bas,
et elle arrive dans nos toilettes.
On ne la différencie pas à l'oeil,
mais elle est juste pas potable.
-Le saviez-vous ?
En France, l'eau des toilettes
est potable.
Elle provient du même raccordement
que l'eau du robinet.
Un énorme gâchis.
Rendez-vous compte :
93 % de l'eau que nous utilisons
l'est pour la lessive, l'entretien,
l'hygiène corporelle.
Un gâchis
qui est évité dans cet immeuble,
construit et géré
par Grenoble Habitat,
le bailleur social,
tenu par les écologistes.
Comment tout cela fonctionne-t-il ?
Pour le savoir,
il faut prendre de la hauteur.
C'est sur le toit de ce bâtiment
que tout commence,
avec ces 1000 mètres carrés
de panneaux solaires.
Ils assurent non seulement
70 % d'autonomie électrique
à l'immeuble,
mais ils ont aussi
une autre fonction, plus originale.
L'architecte Carole Valade
et le directeur technique
de la ville
sont là pour tout nous expliquer.
-Quand il pleut,
l'eau ruisselle
sur les panneaux,
arrive dans les gouttières
qui sont ici
et descend dans ces tuyaux
jusqu'au local de potabilisation,
au rez-de-chaussée.
-Vous l'avez compris,
tout repose
sur un complexe technique,
situé en bas.
Nous redescendons.
Le saint des saints du bâtiment,
le voici.
-L'eau collectée est sous nos pieds,
il y a 150 mètres cubes
de stockage d'eau.
-Les eaux de pluie
sont stockées ici,
avant d'être traitées
dans la station de potabilisation.
-Donc,
un filtre à charbon actif ici,
pour un premier traitement
au niveau de l'eau,
et derrière,
un bioréacteur à membrane
qui vient aussi assurer
le second traitement
avant le passage en filtration
et traitement UV.
Et puis après donc,
on arrive sur la partie
du dernier équilibrage
de la potabilisation,
avec des traitements acido-basiques.
-Un traitement complexe.
Il s'agit d'éliminer toute acidité,
tout micro-organisme vivant
qui pourrait s'y trouver.
L'eau de pluie est mélangée
avec de l'eau municipale
qui apporte les minéraux
pour la rendre complètement potable.
Ensuite, il y a ce qu'on appelle
les eaux grises,
les eaux issues des éviers,
baignoires et machines à laver.
-On reconnecte
au niveau lavabos, douches
et matériels électroménagers
pour revenir traiter
ces eaux grises
et redesservir ça dans les WC
et au niveau du jardin,
pour l'arrosage.
-L'eau des toilettes est évacuée
vers les centres d'assainissement
de la ville.
Impossible de la traiter ici.
Cela nécessite des installations
bien plus grandes.
Alexandre est bien heureux
en son jardin.
-Et là, on peut donner
un petit peu d'eau
à ces betteraves qui...
Ah, elles ont pris
un peu la chaleur.
-Il reste encore trois ans
d'expérimentation,
mais les résultats sont déjà là.
En moyenne, les habitants
consomment 80 litres d'eau par jour,
contre 148 pour le reste
de la population.
Le modèle serait transposable
à l'échelle
d'un quartier de 1000 logements,
malgré les coûts.
Cet immeuble très technique
nécessite de gros investissements.
Le bailleur y a dépensé
13 millions d'euros.
Mais l'avenir n'a pas de prix,
n'est-ce pas ?
-François Gemenne,
La technologie va-t-elle pouvoir
nous sauver de nous-mêmes ?
-A elle seule, non.
On va avoir besoin
de la technologie,
et ce qui était présenté ici
est tout à fait innovant
et remarquable.
Evidemment, ça permet de mettre
en place des mesures de sobriété.
L'eau des toilettes,
c'est une aberration,
mais les gens
ne décident pas eux-mêmes
de leur système de raccordement.
Donc, il faut mettre en place
ce type de solutions.
Par contre,
la technologie ne peut pas
servir d'alibi pour perpétuer
toute une série de modèles du passé
qui vont littéralement se fracasser
sur le mur du changement climatique.
Le défi que nous avons
en tant que société, c'est de voir
comment se servir de la technologie
tout en repensant certains modèles
et comment
la technologie peut nous aider
à repenser certains modèles.
-La redevance de l'eau est payée
à 90 % par les usagers domestiques,
alors qu'ils n'utilisent
que 22 % de l'eau produite.
L'agriculture, elle, en paie 3 à 4 %
alors qu'elle en consomme 45 %
et, en été, jusqu'à 80 %.
Est-ce équitable ?
-Non, mais on pourrait le dire
pour l'eau, on peut le dire aussi
pour le kérosène,
pour toute une série
d'usages du carbone.
Aujourd'hui,
le problème économique,
l'échec du marché,
c'est que les impacts
environnementaux
ne sont pas pris
en compte dans le prix.
Et un gros enjeu,
c'est d'internaliser cela,
de manière à mettre en place
un prix équitable pour tous,
et pas que pour l'eau.
Sans cette question d'équité,
on aura des conflits.
-D'où la tarification progressive ?
-Bien sûr.
Il y a une volonté de rééquilibrage.
Vous auriez pu citer le nucléaire.
On utilise de l'eau
pour de la production d'énergie,
alors qu'il y a aujourd'hui
une cotisation
qui est quasiment de zéro
et qu'il faut
qu'on intègre dans le prix
pour pas partir
dans n'importe quelle direction.
Notre fiscalité fait
comme si nous avions
des ressources gratuites
et infinies.
-Les centrales nucléaires
sont gourmandes en eau.
Le refroidissement des réacteurs
capterait 30 %
de la ressource,
alors qu'on examine la loi
sur de nouveaux réacteurs.
Le nucléaire est-il viable
à l'heure
de la raréfaction de l'eau ?
-Les centrales actuelles
peuvent se faire du souci.
Il y a eu souvent des arrêts...
La température de l'eau
étant trop chaude,
ils ne pouvaient pas rejeter
de l'eau chaude dans le milieu.
Et effectivement, je crois,
dans le projet,
il y a eu très peu
de centrales sur des rivières
parce que je pense
qu'on peut s'inquiéter
des débits d'étiage insuffisants.
-La baisse du débit du Rhône
et de ses affluents
devrait s'accélérer.
Comment continuer à assurer
une production nucléaire
et hydroélectrique ?
-Vous avez une étude
très intéressante
de la Cour des comptes,
dans le cadre de l'évolution
de la politique énergétique,
qui liste les recommandations
qui sont probables.
On a des technologies
de circuit fermé
au lieu du prélèvement,
mais qui posent des soucis.
-Absolument.
-Bon. On a globalement
des solutions technologiques,
selon votre idée :
ne pas imaginer
que la technologie va tout régler,
mais ce n'est pas qu'en transformant
nos comportements qu'on fera face
à une partie des défis
qui sont en face de nous.
Moi, ce que je souhaiterais dire
par rapport à ça,
c'est que là, la logique,
c'est le principe de précaution.
Pourquoi l'eau est potable
dans le fond des toilettes ?
Parce que si un enfant buvait
cette eau,
on pourrait se retrouver
avec un risque
de procès
sur les conséquences de ça.
20 % de fuites en moyenne
sur nos réseaux d'eau potable.
20 % de fuites !
1 litre d'eau sur 5 qui est produit.
Ca montre l'ampleur
de ce qu'on a à conduire
parce que ce sont des moyennes,
et que vous avez des endroits
avec 70 % de fuites.
On a 2000 communes
qui se sont retrouvées en fragilité
avec des risques de perte
d'eau potable,
plutôt des villages,
mais on n'est pas à l'abri
que des agglomérations de taille
plus importante soient confrontées
à ces difficultés.
-Le maître mot,
ce sera la sobriété.
On ne le répétera jamais assez,
le passé éclaire l'avenir.
Charlotte Epale est allée fouiller
dans les archives de l'INA.
Elle nous a exhumé ceci.
C'est notre coup d'oeil
dans le rétro, et c'est maintenant.
-Un bruit bien sympathique
quand il fait 29 degrés à l'ombre.
Un bruit d'eau, bien entendu.
Un bruit d'eau dans un puits
au sud de la Seine-et-Marne.
Monsieur,
vous êtes cultivateur,
je crois, en céréales.
-Oui, oui.
-Vous avez eu des ennuis
dans cette sécheresse ?
-Eh bien, il est certain
que nos récoltes ont souffert
de la sécheresse.
Par exemple, moi,
producteur de maïs,
on pallie quand même
avec l'arrosage.
Je fais de l'irrigation,
j'ai un puits privé.
-Donc, vous avez de l'eau, alors ?
-Pour mes récoltes, oui.
-Je m'excuse de vous interrompre.
Vous êtes conseiller général
du département.
Que pouvez-vous donner
comme conseils
à nos téléspectateurs ?
-Il faut absolument, aujourd'hui,
ne pas qu'ils aient une psychose
de manque d'eau
et que tous les soirs,
sous prétexte
"on a entendu dire
qu'on allait manquer d'eau",
on remplisse les baignoires,
on remplisse toutes les citernes,
on remplisse les bouteilles...
-Et cette eau, on l'utilise pas !
-On ne l'utilise pas,
on la vide le lendemain matin
dans le ruisseau,
et puis quand on voit que l'eau
recommence à couler au robinet,
on recommence à remplir.
-Vous êtes maire de Villemer.
-Mais oui.
-Voulez-vous me parler
du problème de l'eau chez vous ?
-Eh bien, le problème de l'eau
chez nous...
Nous sommes fournisseurs d'eau.
-Alors, vous ne manquez de rien !
-Si, nous sommes fournisseurs d'eau
à la Ville de Paris
qui a capté notre source en 1900,
nous laissant en tout et pour tout
200 m3 par jour.
En 1900, c'était suffisant,
tout le monde avait son puits.
Maintenant, on a l'adduction d'eau,
comme partout,
mais les 200 m3
ne suffisent plus.
En ce moment,
par la sécheresse qui fait,
le soir, dans le petit hameau
où nous sommes en ce moment,
il n'y a plus d'eau.
-François Gemenne,
et j'aimerais terminer là-dessus,
vous rappelez
qu'il est possible
pour une entreprise
de se transformer radicalement.
Nokia fabriquait
des bottes en caoutchouc
avant les téléphones.
Nintendo vendait
des cartes à jouer
avant ses consoles de jeu,
et American Express
- le saviez-vous,
Christophe Béchu ? -,
c'était des diligences
avant de se lancer
dans des cartes de crédit.
Shell vendait des antiquités
et des coquillages
avant de devenir
un géant pétrolier.
Rien n'est perdu,
à qui a envie de se réinventer.
-Elles n'existeraient plus
si elles n'avaient pas changé
leur mode de vie.
-Je vous donne rendez-vous
le mois prochain.
Merci à tous.
D'ici-là, serrons-nous les coudes
et bon courage.
-Merci à vous.
Il y a du boulot pour tout le monde.
Toute la société doit bouger,
pas seulement ceux qui prennent
des décisions.
Il y a un enjeu
pour embarquer tout le monde.
-On y va.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...